con el rostro pintado sombrero de piel y
cuernos este hombre se ha convertido en
uno de los símbolos de los disturbios en
el capitolio estadounidense de 32 años
jake angeli se encuentra actualmente
bajo custodia por cargos que incluyen
entrada violenta y alteración del orden
público dos días antes del asalto
así se expresaba este seguidor ferviente
de donald trump donald trump ganó la
noche de las elecciones lo que estamos
presenciando es una revelación real y
completa de lo corrupto que es el
sistema se hace llamar a sí mismo un
chamán de la teoría conspirativa cuya
non de extrema derecha que asegura que
el presidente trump está librando una
guerra secreta contra los pedófilos de
la élite en el gobierno las empresas y
los medios de comunicación otras decenas
de personas también han sido arrestadas
en este contexto incluyendo un hombre
que fue filmado liderando a un grupo en
el interior del capitolio por desoír
órdenes policiales enfrenta cargos
federales de allanamiento y alteración
del orden y es probable que detenciones
y cargos aumenten mientras los
investigadores buscan en las redes
sociales para identificar a los
asaltantes
richard barnet de 60 años ha sido
inculpado a este individuo de arkansas
en lo capto sentado con los pies sobre
el escritorio de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
ella no está valorando el escritorio así
que pensé en sentarme y apreciarlo apoyó
los pies sobre el escritorio la policía
también ha arrestado a adam johnson el
hombre que fue fotografiado llevándose
el atril de pelos y según el fbi cientos
de sus agentes están buscando en todo el
país pistas para llevar a más atacantes
ante la justicia